thank you all I follow the instruction
of the organizer of the
grunts provocative question or synthetic
connection from the discussion that will
open up the floor for conversation so I
awesome I would have some synthetic
connection and one or two provocative
questions the synthetic connection will
be this observation on the speaker mr.
bill hatin the first speaker right no
this town the problem yeah I follow the
program so I mix up he said something
about the Chinese create a lot of smith
with the elite either government or
scholarly early and they don't have the
DD already existing claim but they
invent the claim with those scholar
government or scholarly to create myth
about chinese right on in the South
China Sea niño and favour his
interpreter said is correct well then I
mentioned dr. Viet and objection to his
room Axl in 99 1898 they called Canton
proven chip on the occasion of a
shipwreck say to the friends authority
that once so he's a gentleman on the
case that he said that our Empire sought
at heine all of the oversea there we
don't tinker with so let the ship onal
come to have fun Vietnam to ask the
officer they are settled matter so it's
obviously the Chinese under the Qing
Dynasty deny any jurisdiction over
beyond Hina
same with the map given by Macau to
seizing pain and so mr. Hayton is right
but he may be wrong in the sense that he
said the Vietnamese have some people on
the unfit to it I'll and the Chinese had
that and mr. Viet oh no mr. Viet
objectively business the observers and
he said the woody island is the only one
the Vietnamese has the rest is not and
not in the Vietnamese authority there he
mentioned some Japanese company and I
have this dispatch the Japanese company
mitsui boots on Keysha told the French
they respect the French authority in in
ddd ddd and filtrate area and UT area so
any night 19-20 they also sent a
scientific mission there 1930s the
protest when the Chinese are they
established material is station than in
1946 they protest republic of china on
that area so mr. via may not be aware of
these things that there are the friends
authority being recognized by the child
but by the japanese company and mr.
Hayton may be wrong in saying it's
chinese create a lot of myth another
people mr. Chung they discuss about the
matter I already mentioned my my
reaction so I wouldn't talk about it
again mr. Sun mentioned a lot of
historical facts that I am glad I don't
have to repeat in my
top tomorrow because even the judge in
the choral music is to us the testimony
that just the facts ma'am because the
facts decide the issue but the facts
have been presented by mr. Jenkins earth
tomorrow I don't have to talk too much
about the fact i was talk about the law
so those are the things i would like to
say that the syntactic connection is
chinese create a lot of mix miss miss
and there is the question that i would
like to put that is the Chinese rely on
study by whom de chu and button so he I
mean [ __ ] you know part is that right
and those are the Chinese in the Korean
that approach honest to no back seat
next to me I'd have a law school office
and I am the one who is provoked by him
to begin investigating South China Sea
and I read his papers very carefully so
I agree with mr. Hayton dead these are
the guy who for Chinese and because of
them the the mid creation of the of the
Chinese need to be debunked by scholars
in conference like this and I hope that
this is a question before us for also
issues and not only Vietnamese or us
thank you
what what I'm going to do is is kind of
step back and speak a little more
conceptually about the idea of
sovereignty and and to think about what
i call a historical approach to
sovereignty and i think this is
something that that all four of the
papers on this panel do really well I'm
a historian and I think that in in
recent years there have been a lot of
scholars who have become interested in
in sovereignty and in trying to use
history to think about sovereignty in a
way that's different perhaps from the
way that that political scientists and
lawyers and philosophers have
traditionally thought about it I want to
start with by referencing a European
historian by the name of James shiiin
shiiin has pointed out that there's
always a gap between the theory of
sovereignty and the actual historical
practice of sovereignty in theory
sheehan points out sovereignty is always
what he calls a chunk it's sort of an
all-or-nothing thing either you have it
or you don't or at least you're you're
trying to get it in practice however
when you actually look at sovereignty
and how sovereignty is constituted or
how states attempt to to constitute or
wield sovereignty sovereignty isn't a
chunk it's he uses another metaphor he
describes it as a basket and
specifically is a basket of claims
claims about authority or rights over
territory over people over institutions
or over material resources the advantage
of this approach according machine is
that the this way of thinking about
sovereignty is a basket of claims I
think it opens up a more historical and
a more contingent approach to the study
of sovereignty sovereignty is something
that's constructed but it's also
something that's practice so we have to
kind of get into the to the historical
details and I think all of the the
papers do this quite well
in the case of the what I should say
about the the claims about the
sovereigns claims these claims can be
administrative or military in nature and
that tends to be the thing we think
about when we think about sovereignty we
look for claims that states are making
to administer particular territories or
to administer particular groups of
people and we look at military forces
and the exercise of military power the
deployment of military forces and
certainly that's important in the
history of sovereignty but we also have
to look at economic claims scientific
claims technological claims claims
relating to transportation the rights to
move through or across certain areas the
rights to trade these are also very
important elements that are constitutive
of sovereignty and I think all of the
papers in their own way actually bring
this up we have mention of of the the
French scientific operations in in the
South China Sea bill suggest that that's
actually how the French first cain't
became interested in making sovereign
claims over the South China Sea we have
a discussion of various economic
activities everything from collecting
bird's nest to bird [ __ ] I guess and so
and then of course I think in chris's
paper part of the the purpose for the
maps as I understood it is to delineate
certain trade routes or certain
transportation routes that this is that
this is part of the activity of the
construction of the nine-dash line and I
think it's really important for us to
pay attention to this when we think
about the South China Sea and we think
about the history of of these the
sovereign claims that different states
have have put forward I would also argue
that a historic approach can provide a
very useful counterpoint to the claims
that are being put forward by
governments and by nationalist
historians today because those
governments and historians are almost
always framing sovereignty in again in
that in that chunk like form rather than
thinking about it as as a basket of
claims
I just wanted to raise sort of a couple
of questions the the first one has to do
with Tong ties idea of the the geo body
with which both bill and and Chris
raised and this is I think you know Tom
choice book of course was a very
important book in the study of
nationalism and in the study of
cartography and and I think there's
there's some very interesting concepts
that we might be able to borrow and
apply here I do wonder though if there
are differences between maritime geo
bodies and landed geo bodies and and if
we might if we might think about that
about the the differences in the ways in
which sovereign claims are our advanced
and asserted on sea or in maritime areas
as opposed to landed areas and what the
implications of that might be for
understanding the history of claims
about the South China Sea the other
question I'll ask is is for enrico hear
about the spitzbergen approach which is
which is really fascinating I share
Michelle's appreciation for for you
bringing this up there I think the
question is do we have to think about
the particular circumstances in Europe
after World War Two that gave rise to
this that enabled this and if we are
going to put this forward as a model for
the South China Sea what are the the
particular conditions that that would
have to obtain in the South China Sea or
which states and diplomates might have
to work to achieve in order to implement
it so the first question which i think
is perhaps already been alluded to is
who is nor wet in the South China Sea
presumably we're not going to sign
sovereignty of the Paracels over to the
actual country of Norway and so so
you know who who exactly is going to
play that role I think I think I'll just
leave my comments there as I said I i
really enjoyed listening to these papers
and in hearing about this I think all of
you are doing really important work and
I really do think that the history of
the South China Sea is going to be very
integral to thinking about it going
forward and hopefully finding some kind
of solution that will allow us to reduce
tensions in the area thank you